circular arrangements are a particular
subset of questions you get
in pros and cons and it's really just
one trick to which i want you to
understand conceptually
okay let's have a look at a normal
situation just arranging four instances
let's go with four cause nice easy
you're arranging four things in four
spots four things in four spots
okay so if i do this we know that there
are
four ways four things you can pick for
the first spot and then
three and then two and then one right so
that's why this becomes
four factorial n factorial depending on
n spots
no problems okay but but
when you take the same four people right
and you want to place them around a
table okay
there's one minor difference okay which
is that if you put for instance if you
put
a here and then b here c here and then d
here
okay that's that's one of the possible
arrangements do you notice
that having the first person let's call
them a had they chosen to sit over
here right but then suppose like um
a's right-handed it's like okay i don't
wanna the next person who arrives like i
don't sit on your right because
you'll keep on bumping with your
chopsticks or whatever okay so b
the second person hey it happens right
um
two people my family left-handed so we
have lots of fun situations like this
b is going to go to the left and you
know suppose you're right-handed so then
c
will go to the left of him and then d
will go to the left of
him because oh well there are no more
spots left right
now when you have a look at this
arrangement let me just redraw it down
here
this green arrangement and the blue one
they're the same arrangement they are
the exactly the same arrangement
if you were to ask each of the people
you know who's to your right
okay if you ask them under this
situation they'll all give you an answer
and if you ask them in this situation
they will still give you the same answer
the same person is to my right every
time all you have to do is just
turn your head 90 degrees to the right
and you're like oh there it is
right a b c d it's identical okay
so what you've done is you have over
counted
how many different ways can i keep on
spinning this table around
and have the same arrangement and the
answer is four ways
okay so i can think about this in two
approaches right
i can say four factorial is fine right
but you've always over counted by
however many chairs you've got
right so this is therefore not going to
be four factorial it'll be four
factorial
and i'm over counting by how many seats
i have
right because i can keep shifting them
around however then you'll notice
right in the same way that we did here
you're like well that's just going to be
three factorial instead of n factorial
it'll be m take away one factorial now
why
would that be how can that unlock a
helpful way to think about this
okay think about this again
when you're the first person right
so you arrive and you look at this setup
okay
now when you look at this all of the
tape the tables throw all of the
chairs around there they look identical
to you don't they
like sitting here just sitting here just
sitting here just sitting here
doesn't make a difference to you right
they're all the same there's no people
to say oh who's on my left on his on my
right okay so therefore
this first person actually contributes
they don't contribute
any extra choices right the first person
doesn't really have a choice
because all the choices are identical
right i guess another way of phrasing
that is
there is inverted commas one place to
sit
which is anywhere okay they all are the
same if
it was here here here or here it's like
well this set of cutlery looks the same
and the same person who's on the left is
on my right
you know i'm in club lonesville right so
therefore
the first person contributes nothing
right but once
he sits down or she sits down
this then becomes the same as our normal
problem
right these positions three and then two
and then one they have an order to them
because you're either going to be on a's
left or ace right or opposite a
right so therefore this is just three
positions to film in any particular way
that's why it's intake away one factor
okay
so all this comes down to is when you
see circles right
just make sure you're not thinking of n
you're thinking of n take away one
and then treat all of your conditions
and restrictions in exactly the same way
that we've already been doing
okay any questions
right yeah
there might be a question where it's
um yeah yes yes
so um what you need to do is pay careful
attention to the restrictions you're
given okay so for instance this exact
one that i mentioned right like oh
um you know mr wu doesn't want to sit to
the left of his brother
because his brother is left-handed okay
which is exactly how i've lived my life
okay therefore therefore what you would
do is you would fix
my brother in a spot and then you work
out the rest of these guys and you just
say i can't sit there
right so you say well i've got two to
choose from
and then you fill the others in two
factorial words okay
so in some way though you've got to turn
this from a circle
right where the positions don't matter
where it's like sit wherever you're
lying
to something where it's like okay this
and then this and then this there are
most riches
okay yeah ms bell also talked about
like necklaces and bracelets and how you
can flip them over and stuff
like yeah um i've sort of already taken
that into account
here when you talk about flipping
something over okay so they're thinking
about this
versus this
okay so i flip these over okay now i
wouldn't worry too much about
the way that was just mentioned because
when you have a look at these
are they the same yes
so i'm going to repeat that original
question i said to you right which is
that if i asked all of these people
who's on your left right are you going
to give me the same answer for one
versus the other
the answers no you're not this is a
different arrangement right
this could make the difference between
me butting elbows with my brother
or dinner like and for a chinese vegas
like three hours right
versus having a really lovely evening
these are not the same arrangement
okay so you can't just flip over these
are different permutations
so i can think of them as like auto
matters don't worry about that
okay um where you start to worry about
that is if you have like a series of
identical elements
but we already know how to deal with
identical elements right if i was
arranging
uh blue green blue green
then yes you can flip over but the
flipping has already been taken care of
in saying
well yeah i can swap the two identical
ones right that's your
that's what the effect of flipping has
so i've overcounted so you've taken care
of that it's all good
okay